all right joining us now with more
Wyoming Senator John baraso and by the
way apparently ready to make an
announcement Senator I'm told you have
told nobody about this coming
announcement uh we're glad you chose
this show welcome back it's great to
have you we love the people of Wyoming
except maybe we're a little mad at the
chenies but short of that we like
everyone else um what do you what's
what's on the agenda tonight well people
of Wyoming and of course all your
viewers know that the country was much
better off under President Donald Trump
and Joe Biden continued to fail America
you know when President Trump was in
office we had the best economy in my
lifetime in most of our Lives time we
had uh energy Independence our enemies
feared us and we had a secure border and
now under Joe Biden we have high prices
we have a wide open border this what's
happened at the border the surrender at
the border has allowed 8 million illegal
immigrants into the Country Joe Biden
goes and begs our enemies for fuel and
energy this is a disaster we cannot not
afford another four years of Joe Biden's
failure so if you want to get the
country back on track which is what I
want to do we need a strong Republican
conservative House and Senate and we
need Donald Trump back in the White
House and that's why tonight I am
endorsing Donald Trump for president of
the United States well we appreciate you
picking our show to to tell people um I
will tell you this you know it's
interesting because I get asked a lot of
question by people about Donald Trump
and why does he fight so much why does
he fight so much and he has a good
answer I think and it's that well if he
didn't fight he wouldn't survive number
one but his real fight is on the issues
you're talking about this is a guy that
is going to fight for the things that
work fight for a better economy free and
fair trade deals secure borders energy
Independence there wasn't any one of
those issues when he was president that
was an easy lift what do you make of The
NeverEnding nonstop unrelenting
attacks and and now the use of the legal
system now attempts to to he's never
been charged with with Insurrection but
they want to say take him off the ticket
they don't even want people to have a
chance to vote for him how's that going
to play out uh very poorly for them well
for president Trump they cannot continue
to do this it's not working for them
they know Joe Biden is a weak president
but on the bigger question of are you
better off now than you were four years
ago people overwhelmingly are worse off
now than they were four years ago which
is why Americans are turning to Donald
Trump for president he is the person Joe
Biden has done massive damage to this
country to our border to our economy to
our standing in the world he is weak
he's not up to the job when I look at
Donald Trump and I was with him in
Afghanistan visiting the troops
Thanksgiving of 2019 this was a
commanderin-chief who was loved and
respected by the troops and he was
feared by our enemies and you get Joe
Biden he's a pushover they understand
that so the Democrats they wanted to
impeach him day one when he became
president they've never gotten over the
fact that he defeated Hillary Clinton
and he had me as the chair of his
platform committee at the convention the
New York Times called it the most
Conservative Republican platform in a
hundred years and I don't think they
meant it as a compliment the policies
worked for Donald Trump they're afraid
of him he needs to be back in the White
House and that's why I'm endorsing him
tonight and I will tell you Joe Biden as
president actually scares me now I
really you you can see how compromised
he is cognitively and you know you asked
the question are you better off than you
were four years ago I intellectually
honestly I can't think of a single
policy that he is he has been supporting
that's working uh Senator great to see
you we do love the people of Wyoming
thank hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else